Rock Meyer we do have a clip from Brock
Meyers such a funny show what can you
tell us about this clip I think I'm
drunk now and in the clip right you were
having a few backstage I saw there's no
other way to deal with this what are you
talk that's such a rude thing to say
that's like your oh the only way I can
spend time with total O'Brien
[Music]
that's why that's why our unofficial
name for the show is Thanksgiving cliff
just show it you just let it roll okay
yes yeah your best is yet to come
I promise you thanks Jim hey chance but
you can't expect me to stay sober and a
place this depressing and our very this
is it this is a cool thing you wrote
this play you're in a play that you
wrote I'm not in it what you're in it as
well not but you wrote I wrote it okay
you that's in very pressive our very own
Harlan McCullough is at the Geffen
Playhouse in Los Angeles June 19th
through July 29th and I want to come see
that play because I can't wait I really
I'm blown away that you wrote a play
that's amazing thank you congratulations
a champion Daniel Cormier
you